bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission qu'on rebaptisera bientôt les
blagues de monsieur le maire
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la dernière petite phrase de
monsieur bruno le maire bonjour et celle
bonjour olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue
dans ces caches l'arrivée du coc vite 19
a mis bon nombre d'entreprises en
difficulté nombreux sont celles qui
craignent de devoir mettre la clé sous
la porte le jour où les aides seront
coupés alors comment les sauver faut-il
annuler la dette de certaines
entreprises on va en parler à dans cette
émission et pour cela en deuxième partie
nous serons en liaison avec stéphane
reynier patron de rca consulting on va
jeter un oeil au nombre de faillites en
france il y en a eu 52 milles en 2019
30000 en 2020 et les prévisions pour
2021 ne sont guère plus réjouissantes 75
mille entreprises pourrait cette année
baisser le rideau est définitivement une
situation qui pousse un petit peu plus
l'exécutif au chevet de cette ces
entreprises
ainsi bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie a proposé tout simplement
d'effacer l'ardoisé de certains
établissements les détails avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine bassesse
[Musique]
c'est la proposition choc de bruno le
maire lycée voire annuler la dette de
certaines entreprises pour éviter une
cascade de faillites dans les mois à
venir après la cessation des aides
massives des aides qui pour les secteurs
non prioritaires devraient diminuer
progressivement dès le mois de juin en
2020 en pleine crise qu vides il y a eu
grâce au soutien quoi qu'il en coûte de
l'état vingt mille entreprises de moins
qui ont mis la clé sous la porte par
rapport à une année classique
de là à croire que certaines ont été
sauvés alors qu'elle n'aurait pas dû
l'être mais en 2021 on estime qu'elles
pourraient être 75000 l'état cherche
donc des solutions et sort donc sexy de
son chapeau
la banque de france estimé de toute
manière que près de 5% des six cent
soixante quinze mille entreprises ayant
bénéficié des 137 milliards de prêts
garantis par l'état depuis le début de
la crise ne pourrait de toutes façons
pas les rembourser
une mesure qui si elle est appliquée
laisse beaucoup de questions en suspens
comment seront sélectionnés des
entreprises qui bénéficieront d'une
ardoise effacés
ne serait ce pas inégalitaire et anti
concurrentiel vis à vis de celle qu'ils
gardent leur d'être bercy privilégiera
t-il les entreprises bien portante pour
faciliter le redémarrage de l'économie
ussel mal en point pour leur éviter la
faillite
au risque de continuer à alimenter une
certaine long beef ication de l'économie
olivier sans trop entrer dans le détail
pour le moment globalement effacé voir
laisser la dette de certaines
entreprises à une solution viable pour
vous mais non parce que en fait qui va
payer
qui va payer au bout du compte qui paye
si vous effacer une dette qui est je
vous rappelle juridiquement un contrat
privé entre entre un prêteur et un
emprunteur donc déjà l'état se glisse
dans le dans l'eee au milieu d'un couple
si vous voulez et sans lui demander son
avis est donc
déjà s'il est face à imaginer la banque
qui a prêté qui va être en difficulté et
donc il va falloir la recapitaliser et
en fait qui paye à la fin c'est nous
dans nos impôts donc si vous voulez
c'est déplacer un problème et c'est
toujours ce qu'ils font d'ailleurs
depuis depuis des années des années même
des décennies maintenant ils déplacent
les problèmes ils les règles jamais
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas remplacer
pour une entreprise de l'activité par
une dette
on voit bien que c'est pal c'est pas au
même niveau l'activité c'est dans le
compte de résultat la dette c'est dans
le bilan donc on peut pas aujourd'hui
imaginer que ce système va fonctionner
d'autant plus que en effet dans le
tiroir cash ont posé un certain nombre
de questions qui va décider de qui va
rembourser et de qui va pas rembourser 6
et les services de monsieur le maire
vous avez des tas de gens qui n'ont
jamais mis les pieds dans une entreprise
je doute que ça marche qui va-t-il
privilégier évidemment ses petits
camarades de jeu et ceux qui peuvent lui
servir
donc franchement je c'est une c'est une
petite phrase pour moi électoraliste si
vous voulez pour calmer les gens et
absolument pas une proposition qui qui a
une une validité quelconque
merci olivier tout de suite la deuxième
partie de cette émission
et cette semaine dans ces caches nous
sommes en liaison avec stéphane reynier
bonjour monsieur vous êtes patron de rca
consulting une société qui édite
notamment des logiciels de gestion pour
des experts comptables et de suivi de
trésorerie des entreprises bienvenue
dans ces caches
bonjour vous bonjour merci merci à
olivier il me laissait un petit bout de
parole stéphane reynier avant de rentrer
dans les dans les détails une réaction
pardon à ce qu'a dit le président de la
fédération bancaire française et
directeur général du crédit agricole il
a assuré chez nos confrères de bfm tv
qu'il n'y avait pas de mur de la dette
le dispositif global a fonctionné et on
a à peu près aujourd'hui le tissu
économique qui existait est début 2020
vous qui êtes au contact de tpe et de
pme est ce que c'est aussi quelque chose
que vous constatez aurait coûté c'est
très intéressant votre question on se
rend compte que tout le monde a joué sa
partition l'état les banques les experts
comptables qui ont qui ont fait le job
pour préserver le dirait le cache de
survie des entreprises et donc
effectivement on se retrouve avec un
effectif d'entreprise qui est
pratiquement resté identique et on a
vous l'avais dit dans votre sujet tout à
l'heure dans votre animation un nombre
de faillites qui a été vraiment
historiquement peu élevé donc qui prouve
que ça fonctionnait le tout petit
problème c'est que on en parlera
peut-être un peu plus tard on se
retrouve avec probablement entre 15 et
20 % d'entreprises en france et
notammment plutôt des tpe ou des tpe qui
sont des sortes d'entreprises zombies
qui n'ont aucune existence virtuelle
aujourd'hui
donc faut se méfier de les apparences et
je pense que effectivement on risquerait
quant à marie va se retirer d'avoir des
très très mauvaises surprises alors
justement on en revient à cette
déclaration de bruno le maire s'était
fait à la mi avril
on ne va pas attendre que l'entreprise
se prennent le mur on va regarder sa
situation l'étudier tous ensemble et
voir s'il faut étaler sa dette voire
annuler sa dette en partie une
entreprise saine elle doit pouvoir
survivre à la crise est allé voir
annuler les dettes des entreprises au
cas par cas vous quel est votre votre
position est sûre cette hypothèse
envisagée par bercy alors effectivement
je reviens sur ce qu'elle dit olivier un
instant bien sûr un moment donné les
dettes
elles reviendront toujours sur le dos de
ceux qu'ils vont devoir les payer à un
moment donné ça va se faire probablement
d'ici quelques mois ou quelques années
pour autant même si ce genre de
dispositif peut sembler très utopique
voire totalement irréaliste et comme le
disait olivier un petit peu à visée
électoraliste
c'est possible on va rentrer dans une
année avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
d'élections je pense que c'est pas c'est
pas totalement incohérent et d'ailleurs
il faut quand même sur place et par
rapport à la situation actuelle
aujourd'hui les banques sont en train de
demander aux entreprises de se
positionner pour dire je rembourse là
tout de suite mon pge où je l'amorti sur
plusieurs années cet amortissement
consomme au dos il va s'arrêter en demi
le 24-25 dont on ne sait pas encore très
bien en tout cas avec un taux un taux
modéré de 2 2 points de lui ce qui est
quand même plutôt assez intéressant pour
les entreprises
le tout petit problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est que cette durée
d'amortissement est beaucoup trop courte
pourquoi parce que les entreprises
devraient faire on l'assimilé nous dans
nos outils à peu près 120 à 130 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires de 2019 donc
beaucoup mieux que ce qu'il faisait en
2019 qui était plutôt une bonne année
pour arriver à amortir qu'en si peu
d'années et donc c'est complètement
impossible parce qu'en plus on cumule
quand même les handicaps aujourd'hui on
a on a une explosion des prix des
matières premières on a des problèmes
d'approbation au delà des secteurs
fragiles qui vont mettre des mois à se
remettre voir des sablés à se remettre à
leur niveau d'avant et même certains
secteurs jeu pas comme l'aéronautique
c'est quand même assez fortement
compromis par rapport à des aspects non
seulement sanitaire mais surtout
climatique année électorale on le sait
risque de mouvements sociaux on peut pas
les exclure totalement enfin bref quand
on regarde tout ça ça semble assez
utopique de penser que les entreprises
vont pouvoir
faire ces 120 à 130 % du chiffre
d'affaires qu'elle réalisait l'année
précédente
donc à un moment donné pour revenir à la
solution d'ailleurs qui a été préconisée
par plusieurs économistes également et
par quelqu'un que je fasse je connais de
réputation qui s'appelle rené ricol qui
a été quelqu'un d'éminents dans la
profession comptable puisqu'il était
président de la compagnie les
commissaires aux comptes président de
l'ordre des experts-comptables et il a
travaillé pour nicolas sarkozy pour
françois hollande tout au long des
dernières années je pense que se
demandait si on peut pas la barre du
tribunal
en bout de chaîne des procédures
collectif et collectives reprendre cette
dette est en tout cas à l'écraser alors
l'écraser part à différentes modalités
ça ça reste à définir
c'est pas forcément idiot dans la mesure
où on peut penser que garder des patrons
de tpe pme dans l'emploi dans ce qu'ils
savent faire
là où il était rentable hors crise
sanitaire je pense que c'est pas idiot
d'autant que ce sont des gens en moyenne
assez âgés ils retrouveront jamais
quelque chose au niveau emploi salarié
et on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
de gens dans ce profil là recréer
d'autres affaires qui sont encore plus
fragiles que les précédentes et en plus
on perd l'écosystème des tpe/pme des
commerces des artisans des professions
de services etc qui sont dont on a
besoin dans nos villes et nos campagnes
aussi donc c'est pas c'est pas chez les
dires des cônes en passant en un mot un
peu un peu un peu argotique c'est pas
d'écho dans simplement il faut arriver à
éliminer de ce sauvetage et là j'en suis
tout à fait d'accord avec olivier
il faut éliminer des gens qui méritent
pas ce soutien et ce soutien
ça peut être quelques dizaines de
milliers d'euros c'est pas forcément
beaucoup d'argent pour ces entreprises
par contre les canards boiteux on sait
les identifier à vous demander un expert
comptable à vous demander à des
banquiers ils savent tous quels sont les
gens qui étaient déjà mal fin 2019 début
2020 donc
je pense que sur les 15 20 %
d'entreprises zombies qu'on a
aujourd'hui en france on peut on peut
imaginer qu'on est dans cette eau là il
ya au moins trois quarts des entreprises
qui pourraient être sauvées par des
mesures de ce type là
l' avantage aussi c'est qu'on éviterait
de repartir dans des aides advitam
eternam qu'on ne sera jamais remboursé
dans les entreprises malaisiennes
réaction à ce que vient de dire jamais
fait régner
oui je suis d'accord sur le sur
l'ensemble la seule chose si vous voulez
c'est que c'est que on sait très bien
que malheureusement ça se passera pas
comme ça c'est à dire qu'on va aider on
l'a bien vu d'ailleurs il n'ya pas il ya
peu de temps je vais vous donner un
exemple qui était qui est criant on a
versé un prêt garanti par l'état à
arnaud lagardère dont on sait très bien
que il détruit l'entreprise qui avait
été construite par son père depuis
depuis des années et qui s'appliqua à
rendre cette cette société qui était
rentable une entreprise sont bi on lui
prête de l'argent on lui prête de
l'argent
pas parce que il lui en fallait pour
passer le coc vide
on lui prête de l'argent tout simplement
parce que son entreprise ne gagne pas
d'argent et que malheureusement elle
travaille dans la presse et que on a
besoin de la presse pour 2022 donc on
est sur des sur des ddd conflit
d'intérêts si vous voulez où on aide les
amis et on laisse tomber le reste du
monde je vous rappelle tout de même que
c'est ce gouvernement et la gestion de
cette crise qui a empêché l'activité
qu'ils étaient des activités rentables
jusqu'à maintenant jusqu'en 2019 comme
oublié très bien et maintenant qu'on les
a empêchés de travailler on va on leur a
mis de la dette sur le sur le leu leu la
tête et on leur dira mais vous inquiétez
pas on va annuler cette bête mais c'est
quoi ce système c'est un système où on
remplace du chiffre d'affaires par de la
dette
c'est complètement incohérent alors moi
je veux bien que
sur certaines boîtes qui en effet son
tangente
on est on étale un petit peu plus la la
le remboursement de la dette pourquoi
pas mais l'annulation de la dette aura
des conséquences il faut le savoir
on aura des conséquences avec les bang
bang qui était déjà pas bien en avant la
crise du coc vide qui vont l'être encore
moins après la crise du coc vide et donc
au final on aura exactement comme
d'habitude les mêmes qui vont payer
c'est à dire tous ceux qui payent des
impôts et à qui on va demander de régler
l'addition
or on peut pas tout le temps régler
l'addition des bêtises que font nos
gouvernants
si vous laissez pas les bêtises des
sociétés lasser les bêtises qu'on fait
nos gouvernants et qu'il faut après
réparer
donc on en sort on n'en sortira jamais
alors messieurs avant d'évoquer les
conséquences d'un possible effacement la
tête on va marquer une courte pause et
on vient dans un instant bienvenue dans
ces caches si vous nous rejoignez au
sommaire cette semaine on va parler du
possible effacement de la dette de
certaines entreprises et pour cela nous
sommes en liaison avec l stephan reynier
patron de rca consulting alors monsieur
régné dans la façon dont bercy compte
s'y prendre deux pistes seraient
envisagées selon nos confrères de france
info
la première le renforcement du rôle des
codefi ces organismes départementaux et
qui permettent la restructuration de
dette privée
et puis la deuxième piste serait à la
transformation de l'argent prêté en
capital par exemple pour les pge est les
prêts garantis par l'état les banques
privées prête aux sociétés qui en font
la demande dans le cas d'une
impossibilité à rembourser c'est l'état
qui prend le relais pour rappel 675 mhz
et l'entreprise sont concernés par ces
pg e pour un montant de 137 milliards
d'euros
la solution est elle dans ces deux
pistes stéphane reynier écouter quand on
reprend la 1ère l'écho défi on est
toujours dans le
dans le principe des aides diverses et
variées donc on n'en sort pas le
problème c'est qu on déresponsabilise
les chefs d'entreprises et on l'a vu des
entreprises qui auraient dû déposer le
bilan il ya déjà pas mal de moi l'ont
pas fait en se disant il ya toujours
l'aide de plus qui va sortir dans claj
là je rejoins à 1000% olivier delamarche
sais quel moment donné on peut pas peut
pas continuer ad vitam aeternam à
subventionner tout le monde et à sortir
le porte-monnaie d'une façon qui parfois
aussi parce qu'on traite des telle
quantité de dossiers
je pense en haut lieu que on peut pas
être très sélectif ou alors sinon ça
prendrait des mois et la crise elles
seraient passées et les gens seraient
tombés donc c'est pas possible je pense
que tous les aspects après lié au fait
de remonter des dettes ou capitale tout
ce qui est prêt participatif qui était
aussi une autre idée mais on est là on
parle que des très grandes boîtes
françaises
tout ça je pense que la remontée de
dette capital peut être de nature à
aider à faire en sorte que la notation
bancaire de l'entreprise soit pas trop
dégrader et que l'entreprise puisse
toujours à la fois emprunté et emprunter
à des taux convenable parce que la renta
il faut savoir que la rentabilité des
entreprises françaises et pas l'une des
meilleures en europe et donc au delà de
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure on sait
que avec ses rentabilité là on est
obligé d'avoir des conditions très
favorables pour arriver à rembourser
quelque chose donc moi je pense que le
l'étape de l'urgence qu'on a vécu
aujourd'hui et le dirai
grosso modo cette idée de cette idée de
prendre en charge des les dettes des
entreprises
pour moi c'est un peu ça toutes
proportions gardées c'est un peu c'est
un peu le vaccin du dernier recours quoi
mais le vaccin
ça veut dire aussi qu'on a peut-être des
traitements qui pourraient être
alternatif qui pourrait être meilleur ça
je peux vous en parler un instant et je
dirais à moyen long terme on peut faire
de la prévention aussi mais quand on est
toujours et là je suis encore une fois
très d'accord avec olivier quand on est
toujours à soigner les choses une fois
qu'elles sont arrivées
c'est toujours trop tard quand même
moment donné il faut arrêter ça il faut
remonter le sujet beaucoup plus haut on
peut donner le culture aux entreprises
pour qu'elles les gèrent mieux leur
trésorerie on peut donner des méthodes
pour accélérer leur trésorerie et faire
en sorte de se sauver ou quelques mois
ça il ya des méthodes qui existent
aujourd'hui qui sont ignorés de tout le
monde est très ignoré en france et en
fait on a avant de regarder en
détaillant les solutions alternatives
on va regarder ce qui se passe olivier
du côté de la confédération à des pm
pour son président françois asselin il
ne faudrait pas qu'une annulation pour
une entreprise crée une distorsion de
concurrence avec une autre pme et qui
elle s'emploierait à rembourser ses
dettes fin de citation elle serrait
olive et que la question de la
concurrence déloyale elle serait aussi
évidemment c'est à dire qu'en fait ça et
c'est le sait le sait la personne qui ce
qui se noie et qui entraîne son son
sauveteur au fond de l'eau c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire que si vous
entretenez des entreprises qui aurait dû
mourir qui est qui se sont précipités
sur ce prêt parce qu'elle savait que ça
allait leur permettre de deux pompes et
encore un peu d'argent pendant quelques
pendant quelques mois
et bien en fait vous entraîner celle qui
pour le coup était était viable par le
fonds tout simplement créant une
concurrence déloyale et en créant une
pression sur les prix etc etc
donc on sait et ça a été d'ailleurs la
politique qu'on a menée
et depuis déjà un certain temps avec les
taux zéro et avec les facilités de
crédit parce que il faut voir que le ce
principe de fonctionner sur la dette
n'est pas un principe qui est apparu au
moment du coc vide c'est apparu bien
avant
or aujourd'hui on a des entreprises qui
ont tenu le choc
parce que on les a soutenus avec des
crédits qui était à zéro des taux
d'intérêt qui était à 0 et ils en ont
permis de tenir et au détriment
d'entreprises qui elle était viable qui
avaient un modèle économique viable et
qui ont été sous pression à cause de
cette surproduction de ses surcapacités
qui étaient dues à des entreprises qui
auraient dû disparaître et qui n'ont pas
disparu grâce à ses taux à zéro donc
faut pas tout mettre encore une fois sur
le dos du coc vide le vide y est là et
c'est clair il a accéléré les choses et
aggravé les choses
mais c'était une situation qui était là
depuis déjà un bon moment et donc la
règle et en ont par des artifices qui
sont va effacer la dette je vous ai dit
la premier mot que je vous ai prononcés
c'était qui va payer au final est pas
parce que au final il y aura il y aura
bien quelqu'un qui va mettre la main à
la poche
et ça il faut le comprendre alors
monsieur bruno le maire se prend pour un
type ex il veut effacer toutes les
dettes les dettes de l'état les dettes
des entreprises ecsta simplement si on
se posait la question de ne pas aller
faire les dettes ça serait déjà pas mal
ça serait intéressant plutôt que de les
faire et après d'essayer de les régler
ses fans renier rapidement à une
réaction sur cette question de
concurrence déloyale
quand je peux je pense que je vais
élargir un petit peu par rapport à la
réponse d'olivier à l'instant je pense
que c'est un calcul économique il faut
qu'on fasse un moment donné encore une
fois je suis d'accord sur le principe
ses dettes il faudrait pas les avoir ou
encore moins à les créer
bien évidemment soin qu'on peut pas être
trop intégristes un moment donné parce
que qu'est ce qui va se passer
supposons qu'on fasse rien de spécial et
qu'on continue à laisser tourner un
petit peu le système tel qu'il est
engagé aujourd'hui on peut avoir quand
même plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'entreprises sur plusieurs années qui
vont disparaître ces centaines des
milliers d'entreprises elles vont
occasionner des millions de chômeurs
c'est millions de chômeurs ils vont nous
coûter très cher devant nous coûter des
milliards si peut-être on efface un
ensemble de choses à la source c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure on va
peut-être regarder des gens dans
l'emploi qui vont conserver leur
entreprise et qui vont qui auront une
activité qui était rentable et qui était
pérenne jusqu'à présent et je pense
qu'on peut qu'on peut on peut s'en
sortir comme ça donc je pense que c'est
vraiment du domaine du calcul économique
il faut quand même remarquer qu' on
parle essentiellement des entreprises de
niveau tpe pme qui sont quand même archi
dominante dans le paysage français
aujourd'hui et donc elles sont
nombreuses
elle tenait la route en grande partie
aujourd'hui il faut faire en sorte de
garder cet écosystème business parce que
si on le perd on va aller encore plus
haut au profit on va dire de très très
grande entreprise multinationale qui
sont déjà très puissante sur internet et
qui sont capables de manger tout le
monde on le voit déjà il ya déjà des
débats depuis très longtemps et des
sujets là dessus moi je pense que le
risque sur la distorsion de concurrence
pour revenir à la question précise
quelque part ils s'apprécient on sait
qu'il y aura on sait qu'il y aura des
risques de ce type là tout comme on sait
qu'il ya eu de la gérer de la triche au
moment du chômage partiel il ya quelques
mois on sait qu'il ya des boîtes qui ont
qui sont mis en chômage partiel et qui
ont fait bosser les gens chez eux
bon mais ça on n'y peut rien à un moment
donné on peut pas mettre des flics à
tous les étages dans toutes les
entreprises
on n'arrivera pas à le faire donc un
moment donné je pense qu'il faut jouer
un principe de réalisme et se dire si on
fait pas ça ok on crée pas de la dette
tout de suite là par contre on va créer
de la dette plus tard et je pense que ça
sera peut-être pire de la créer plus
tard olivier régler les problèmes à la
source c'est une chose en attendant la
situation est telle qu'elle est et
comment on fait pour quelle autre
solution qu un effacement de la dette
alors
les autres solutions se serait déjà de
d'arrêter de bloquer l'activité
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
à dire ouvrir ça serait déjà plus
intéressant plutôt que d'avoir une
activité qui est complètement bloquée et
de d'être obligé de suppléer à ce à
cette absence d'activité par de la dette
parce que je vous ai dit c'est pas les
mêmes c'est pas les mêmes poches
donc vous ne pouvez pas régler tous les
problèmes par de la dette
vous ne pouvez pas compenser une absence
d'activité par de la dette c'est idiot
donc il faut arrêter avec ça en plus une
fois qu'on stoppe ce mécanisme de dette
et qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
concrètement une fois que les aides
seront coupés là qu'est ce qu'on fait
complètement fois ci on va être
intéressant parce que justement il
cherche à repousser le moment où ils
arrêteront les aides que ce soit le
chômage partiel que ce soit les prêts
garantis par l'état
ils cherchent à repousser ce moment là
parce qu'ils savent très bien que le
jour où ça s'arrête
il va y avoir un certain nombre de
faillites est un certain nombre de mises
au chômage
le chômage partiel va se transformer en
chômage tout court
et donc qu'ils ont peur de ça parce que
ça peut arriver juste avant les
élections et que ça ferait désordre
donc ils ont peur de ceux de cette chose
là mais si vous voulez le problème c'est
que on rentre un peu dans un système où
es tu sais moi c'est le sait le
précédent qui me tim gêne si vous voulez
on est dans un système où finalement
qu'est ce qui va empêcher les
entreprises qui dont on a effacé la
dette de dire dans six mois on s'en tire
pas on va reprendre une dette et en fait
on fait comme comme le fait un état
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qui ne
rembourse jamais il roule ses dettes
salade est en plein et on sait que ça va
se terminer mal
donc le problème il est là merci avocats
olivier merci à stéphane reynier d'avoir
été parmi nous a dans cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes si tu attendes
rca consulting une société à clé dit des
logis
elle de gestion pour les experts
comptables et de suivi de trésorerie des
entreprises olivier nous on continue
avec les questions cash
merci beaucoup question de bobby olivier
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres moyens qu'un
impôt mondial pour stopper le dumping
fiscal
écoutez déjà il faudrait que les pays
comme par exemple les états unis puisque
c'est une idée de monsieur byden ce qui
est assez savoureux c'est que faut
savoir qu'il était sénateur ou
gouverneur je ne sais plus à qui tenait
un rôle important dans le de la mer l2
là où faire qui est le paradis fiscal
américain si vous voulez donc c'est
assez amusant que c'est le pompier
pyromane si vous voulez donc
maintenant qu'ils nous expliquent qu'il
faut un impôt mondial déjà si les
entreprises américaines parce que c'est
quand même essentiellement elle que ça
concerne c'est toutes les gaffes a un
qui ne payent pas d'impôts là où elle
travaille
si déjà les états unis arrivé à les
imposer ça serait déjà pas mal
avant de se mêler des impôts des autres
vous aurez toujours des pays qui sont
mieux géré que les autres et qui donc
impose - et leurs citoyens et les
entreprises donc moi l'impôt mondial
chez quand même des doutes
merci olivier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez vous la semaine prochaine en
attendant vous pouvez poser toutes vos
questions à olivier sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag rta cacher avant
ce kit est totalement votre dernier mot
liés on vient d'inventer un nouveau
modèle économique
on fait de la bête on les fasse on fait
de la bête on les fasse c'est superbe